bruno retailleau le président des
sénateurs les républicains et candidat
aux régionales dans les pays-de-la-loire
et l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france presse et vous répondrai
au cours de cette émission divisé en 3
donc à trois grandes questions d'abord
est ce que vous êtes choqués par les
arrestations à air france et le procès
qui s'annonce pour cinq salariés
deuxième question que vous posera tout à
l'heure nadège pull jack la primaire de
la droite et du centre est elle menacée
après les réserves de nicolas sarkozy
que vous avez d'ailleurs rencontré ce
matin et qui émet des doutes sur la
possibilité de mettre en place dix mille
bureaux de vote enfin le troisième
question tout à l'heure avec perrine
tarneaud françois hollande at il répondu
à votre lettre du week-end sur
l'évacuation des opposants au projet
d'aéroport à notre dame des landes vous
vous dénoncez une république est
incapable de se défendre vous nous direz
donc si votre missive est votre colère
ont obtenu une réponse de la part du
chef de l'état d'abord bruno retailleau
la polémique qui s'envenime sur les
restes arrestation air france après des
violences contre deux membres de la
direction bien sûr les images choquantes
ont fait le tour du monde proprement
scandaleux dit la cgt et la gauche de la
gauche à propos de ces arrestations
et puis des jugements qui sont annoncées
ce procès de cinq salariés pour
violences aggravées à l'heure vous est
ce que vous êtes choqués par ces gardes
à vue ces arrestations ce procès
absolument pas tout simplement parce que
je considère que force doit rester à la
loi
y'a aucune catégorie de français qui
doivent se sentir au dessus de la loi
depuis quand des syndicalistes parce
qu'ils sont syndicalistes pourraient
avoir recours à la violence et ne pas
être sanctionné par la loi
personne ne le comprendrait je pense que
la violence n'est pas admissible dans un
pays civilisé comme la france on peut
parfaitement manifester on peut
parfaitement faire savoir sa
désapprobation sur des points qui
peuvent concerner un plan notamment sur
la vie de air france mais la violence
est absolument inadmissible que vous
êtes choqué alors par certaines
déclarations polies nature à nier mais
bien sûr monsieur mélenchon un jour de
deuil pour la france
ils se regardent dans la glace
franchement franchement un leader
politique
t'aurais savoir que la loi s'applique à
tous et la définition de la république
je l' ai connu parfois beaucoup plus
sourcilleux alors montré qu'aucun quand
on écoute le secrétaire général de la
cgt numéro un du syndicat philippe
martinez qui lit et lui le geste il
parle de la chemise déchirée aussi le
début d'un lynchage auquel on a assisté
le geste est là est à la hauteur de la
violence sociale du plan de suppressions
d'emplois non il mais c'est donc dans la
balance
non on ne peut pas y avoir d'excusés à
la violence la violence doit être
réprimée d'où qu'elles viennent quelle
qu'elle soit peu importe qu'elles
viennent demain d'un patron aujourd'hui
des syndicalistes après demain de je ne
sais quelle catégorie sociale il n'y a
pas de catégories sociales y compris les
élus qui doivent se sentir donc de la
justice de la loi doit passer à dire que
serge aurier si elle doit être la même
pour tous et ses salariés la définition
de l'état de droit
ces dernières risquent une peine de
trois ans de prison ça vous paraît
légitime trois ans coûtaient je m'en
remettrai à la f6 de mon pays point
d'accord tant que vous avez les mêmes
mots que manuel valls finalement reid
avait d'abord dénoncé les voyous à air
france et puis à ryad
il a expliqué qu'il ne fallait pas
chercher d'excusés à la violence et
qu'il ne fallait pas l'opposé à la
violence sociale twitter
il a raison bah écoutez on peut partager
on n'est pas en guerre civile on peut
pas rêver sur le plan des principes en
tout cas républicain on peut partager la
même fermeté simplement j'observe on
pourra en parler dans quelques instants
mais j'observe que la fermeté de
monsieur valls elle est à géométrie
variable voyage bah oui on en paie
dizaine de personnes sur l'a1 ont bloqué
pendant des heures et des heures
voilà pour faire sortir de prison une
deux personnes et pendant ce temps là il
les automobilistes sur l'autoroute plus
fréquentée de france qui ont été bloqués
ça ça n'est pas normal près ce qu'a fait
monsieur valls à ce moment là
là aussi il doit pas y avoir deux poids
deux mesures françois hollande était sur
vos terres aujourd'hui enfin dans votre
région à saint nazaire il a rendu visite
aux chantiers navals stx
quand un carnet de commandes
formidablement remplir pour les
étudiants mais notre révélant deux fois
le chef de l'état
il l a interpellé par des syndicalistes
et il a défendu la nécessité du dialogue
social là aussi bien sûr voulu donner
parfaitement raison bruno retailleau
l'actualité c'est aussi
lancement du débat sur le budget 2016
c'est à dire ce sera le dernier en année
pleine un du quinquennat du chef de
l'état l'heure des baisses d'impôts se
félicite le ministre des finances michel
sapin on écoute la baisse des impôts en
faveur des entreprises pour leur
permettre d'investir et d'embaucher la
baisse des impôts en faveur des ménages
oui 12 millions de ménages français sur
10 7 millions qui aujourd'hui paient
l'impôt sur le revenu vont bénéficier
d'une baisse de leur impôt sur le revenu
et qu'on ne vienne pas me dire qu'il ne
s'agit pas là des classes moyennes c'est
le coeur des classes moyennes de celle à
qui nous avons demandé un effort mais
auquel il est légitime aujourd'hui de
rendre une partie de cet effort parce
que l'effort était nécessaire mais
aujourd'hui la justice fiscale est
indispensable le chiffre augmente
apparemment remettant en parle de 12
millions de foyers c'est vraiment parler
de 9 jusqu'à présent mais est ce quand
même est-ce que vous reconnaissez que
dans ce budget quand même il y a une
bonne nouvelle pour les contribuables
non je vais vous expliquer les deux
raisons pour lesquelles ce que dit
monsieur sapin c'est au mieux de
l'humour au pire du cylisme premiers
éléments depuis le début du quinquennat
l'augmentation du produit de l'impôt sur
le revenu a augmenté de 20 milliards il
est passé de 50 milliards à 70 milliards
et en même temps la base sur laquelle
s'applique cet impôt est passé 5 un peu
plus de 50% des français à 46%
faut pas être sortis des grandes écoles
de mathématiques pour voir que ce sont
toujours moins de français qui payent
pas russe toujours plus avant deuxième
exemple pour un certain nombre de
familles avec les réformes du quotient
familial
eh bien ces familles notamment qui ont
plusieurs enfants les familles aussi
nombreuses et bien on vu log leurs
impôts augmenter depuis le vendredi
qu'une page est en train de se tourner
un film en l'île maurice mit en tout cas
il ne dit pas la vérité
les chiffres que je vous donne oui bien
sûr et quand un certain nombre de deux
contribuables français ont constaté que
l'impôt foncier vous savez sur des zones
tendues a à peu près 28 grandes
agglomérations en france ont pu
augmenter multiplié par 3 par cinq voire
jusqu'à x 50 vous trouvez que ça valait
réjouir et vous pensez que les propos de
monsieur
sapin pour les couvre les convaincre non
ce qui d convaincrait c'est que les
impôts baissent réellement or les impôts
on ne baisse pas en france et d'ailleurs
on a on est le pays
quel champion du monde de la dépense
publique 57% avec la finlande
mais c'est exorbitant par rapport à
beaucoup d'ouvrières d'euros d'économies
vous les avez déniché vous attendait des
explications
bah écoutez c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est valérie rabault qui valeurs
socialistes lé rapporteur général du
budget elle n'est pas de ma famille
politique et comme vous l'avez dit
socialiste s'est dit vraiment il doit y
avoir un loup commission va durer et
laura toutes les informations et tous
tes confirmation que non mais écoutez je
vous dis très simplement il n'y a pas de
baisse je pense que contrairement à ce
qui s'est passé en allemagne
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé dans
beaucoup d'autres grands pays en 2017 on
à ce programme d'économies de 50
milliards soit disant eh bien en 2017 il
y aura plus de 60 milliards de dépenses
publiques
donc où est la baisse il n'y a pas de
baisse il ya effectivement une
décélération
ça augmente mon avis va le prendre alors
on vous a entendu selon vous pas de
baisses d'impôts pas de baisse des
dépenses publiques et une question se
pose concernant les impôts
bruno retailleau et les dans l'air
d'ailleurs elle est relancé par jean
marc ayrault l'ancien premier ministre
est ce qu'il faut fusionner selon vous
l'impôt sur le revenu et la csg
l'ancien premier ministre est soutenu
par 130 députés ps ah bah oui c'est jean
marc ayrault le frondeur marc ayrault le
fondeur d'ailleurs vous avez le
gouvernement beaucoup de mal ils vont
essayer de l'évacuer son amendement sur
le plfss fin sur plein de portes sur la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
non je moi j'y suis opposée tout
simplement parce que ce serait encore
plus impôts pour une moitié de français
puisqu'il ya un impôt qui est progressif
c'est la csg et l'autre qui est non
proportionnelle vous additionnez les
deux vous ajoutez les deux et ça fait un
cocktail chimique explosif avec de très
fortes hausses d'impôts pour environ 40
45 % de français alors vous l'avez
constaté l'exécutif le chef de l'état et
le premier ministre est très mobilisée
par la situation internationale est ce
que vous avez d'ailleurs relevé la
dimension présidentielle du déplacement
du premier ministre au proche-orient
puisqu'on l'a vu en egypte en jordanie
et en arabie saoudite mais coûteux
ça me choque pas franchement tous les
premiers ministres sur tous les
gouvernements surtout les prisons de
république font des voyages à chaque
fois ces voyages sont calibrés avec le
quai d'orsay avec la cellule
diplomatique à la fois de matignon et de
l'elysée
donc je ne vais pas jeter la pierre le
manuel valls itunes où je trouve
franchement on peut faire des polémiques
qui soit vraie polémique celle ci n en
vous par ailleurs le chef le chef du
gouvernement a évoqué les raids français
sur la syrie qui ont fait des victimes
on l'a appris parmi les djihadistes
parti de france peut être six en écoute
manuel valls les attentats ont déjà eu
lieu il des morts compatriotes qui ont
été tuées par des terroristes
partir du moment où nous savons que ces
attentats les attentats se prépare ici
en syrie
au nom de la légitime défense c'est une
obligation peu de frapper d'acheter deux
continueront quelles que soient les
nationalités les terroristes de ce
produit là vous êtes d'accord
évidemment le terrorisme n'a pas de
passeport bruno retailleau
la terroriste n'a pas de passeport mais
là je suis désolé là je vais critiquer
la position diplomatique de la france
parce que on retrouve dans la position
diplomatique de la france les coûts de
yoyo de françois hollande vous souvenez
quand ils voulaient faire des frappes
punitives sur damas et à l'époque quand
les etats unis se prononcer on a fait un
virage sur l'aide
ensuite il ya quelques mois françois
hollande nous disait faut surtout pas
faire des frappes aériennes sur la syrie
il ya quelques semaines le premier
ministre le ministre sont chères sont
venus à l'assemblée et au sénat pour
dire ne m'en faut frapper des armes au
nom de la légitime défense mais quelle
la légitime défense et de la prévention
écouter le terrorisme la frappe
il allait coûter le terrorisme il a
frappé au moins de janvier bien et moi
je pense que la politique c'est d'abord
s'attaquer aux causes à rennes soigner
les conséquences s'attaquer aux causes
c'est quoi c'est détruire éradiquer dash
éradiquer d'âge ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire frappé des slaouis dahesh en
irak et en six emplois les militaires
français alors oui mais alors avec un
retournement puisque ce sont les toutes
premières frappes valorisé avec une
forme de scénographie de communication a
pris j'ose dire bien sûr communication
politique ce que je veux dire c'est que
mes résultats mais l'âge adressé aux
jeunes français qui seraient tentés de
partir je vais vous dire comment peut-on
détruire d'âge on ne détruira pas des ch
j'y suis allé je veux dire en août 2014
on ne détruira pas dahesh avec des
frappes aériennes plus personne ne le
croirait fait confiance aux russes le
plan je ne fais ni confiance aux russes
ni aux américains je pense que la france
est dé ce pays dans le monde dont la
voix est écoutée au rouge
malheureusement et françois hollande
cette voie elle ne porte plus que
j'attends de la vacance c'est que la
france organise avec les russes avec
l'iran avec les puissances régionales la
turquie qui reste à convaincre qui est
dans un état dans des 8es terrible je
pense qu'il faudra intervenir au sol pas
nous seulement accord mais si on
n'intervient pas au sol
on ne parvient
un pas à éradiquer le terrorisme d'âge
et on ne parviendra pas à arrêter le
flot de réfugiés
pardon de dire ça oui je sais que c'est
un peu politiquement incorrect mais
c'est la vérité
qu'est ce qui est politiquement
incorrect en fait de dire qu'il faut
frapper au sol d'accord les armes et
régionales agissent simplement j'ai ma
question sur la russie s'est on
sectionne assène ses larmes c'est ce
sont les aviez les avions russes qui
aujourd'hui des blés à peu le terrain
pour pour l'armée de bachar el-assad est
ce que ça c'est une bonne démarche que
vous soutenez moi je soutiens
d'abord je tiens jour mon pays mois
évidemment je suis français
parlementaires français je suis patriote
simplement il faut qu'on arrête avec la
russophobie on a besoin de l'iran on a
besoin de la russie pour vaincre des
scouts et ce n'est pas moi qui l'ait dit
vous savez très bien pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale il a fallu tendre la
main staline je suis désolé staline
c'était tout autre chose que bachar al
assad et surtout monsieur poutine pour
vingt ans qu'il faut marcher la main
dans la main non non c'est pas chardy
simplement je dis organisons une grande
qu acteur international avec des troupes
au sol qui ne seront pas prioritairement
occidentales parce que je vais vraiment
mais part majoritaire dans votre camp on
dit qu'il fait noir et des français je
suis désolé en irak vous allez les
forces spéciales pourraient évidemment
est ce que vous imaginez qu'on peut
frapper avec des accents rouler au sol
sans relais mais surprenant donc mais
donc
donc il faut l'assumer les renvoyer les
militaires français ce que ce que je
vais prenant rayé je vais vous dire ce
que je crains c'est que dash est en
train de s'enraciner
je pense que la syrie coagule énormément
je veux dire aujourd'hui de frappe
évidemment et on oublie un peu l'irak
moi je pense qu'on devrait libérer la
plaine de ninive libéré me saoule et
ensuite prendre en tenaille entre damas
et puis l'irak les les forces
terroristes
évidemment cela permettrait d'arrêter de
stopper le flot des réfugiés mais pour
être parfaitement clair vous êtes
favorable à l'envoi de militaires
français au sol en syrie et en et pas
dans n'importe quelle condition encore
une fois devant la porte quelqu'un
d'attachant minoritaire sur ces moments
bien oui on est déjà au sol on est déjà
au sol oui mais ce que je veux c'est que
mon pays
réalise 7 travaillant tous carrés à
cette coalition internationale vous
m'avez pas vraiment répondu sur le petit
extrait convient d'entendre qui parlait
dé des frappes contre les djihadistes
les frappes notamment contre les
français est-ce qu'il faut accentuer si
on a tué six français qui sont partis
faire le djihad là bas est-ce qu'il faut
accentuer ce qui pourrait ressembler à
une politique d'élimination ciblées mais
ces deux français et bien sûr vous il
faut détruire de prendre 20 de français
la part des terroristes on va pas leur
demander d'écrire suivre une formation
pour revenir dans votre pays d'écouté
bien sûr tous les terroristes quelle que
soit leur nationalité
simplement ce que je vous dis c'est que
tant qu'on détruit pas des ch on en tue
six terroristes
et puis on a 20 30 40 cents 200 milles
qui arrivent de toute l'europe du monde
entier voilà aujourd'hui ce qui s'est
passé on a détruit des forces d'âge
elles se sont reconstitués exactement
comme si on n'avait rien fait mais c'est
ce qu'il a été trop discret aujourd'hui
en signant pour vie milliards d'euros de
contrats en arabie saoudite est ce qu il
était trop discret en évoquant pas
publiquement les droits de l'homme dans
un pays qui pratique on le sait la peine
de mort à grande échelle et qui menace
qui a condamné on le rappelle à la
décapitation un jeune opposant chiite
malabo l'émission je pense que le
wahhabisme a fait beaucoup pour la
radicalisation de l'islamisme dans le
monde
ryad de ce point de vue là a une
responsabilité éminente il faut être
capable de le dire simplement je serait
incohérent avec ce que je vous dis ce
que je viens de vous dire je pense que
la politique étrangère c'est aussi de
parler avec tout le monde et d'avoir des
comment dirais-je des réunions
ponctuelles donc manuel valls a raison
de travailler pour l'emploi là bas il a
tort de ne pas dire ce que l'on doit
dire en termes de droits de l'homme aux
autorités de ryad
maintenant ce que j'observe c'est aussi
une incohérence est d'accord ben oui
vous allez demander s'ils étaient pour
ou contre jeudi qu' il
pouvait faire son job de premier
ministre aussi à l'étranger simplement
ce que je dis il est pro business
oui là-bas quand il est en france il est
plutôt frondeurs d'accord mais là la
question c'est est une chose la question
c'était sûr sur la france qui porte le
message des droits de l'homme qui va
signer aujourd'hui je pars avec un
régime on peut pas juger féodal
on avait quand même démentir on peut que
réserve des heures le jeune homme
le jeune ali levé nally qui condamne un
peu de la peine de mort j'ose espérer
qu'il a demandé sa grâce
j'ose espérer tout simplement parce
qu'il a manifestée et la peine de mort
c'est la décapitation est ensuite la
crucifixion des décors et l'exposition
aux déchets et l'exposition à ces ça
donc je dire que ça nous interroge donc
je je servais j'ose penser jose pense je
veux lui faire ce crédit je veux lui
faire ce crédit qu'il en ait parlé aux
autorités de ryad dans le secret de
leurs échanges en tous les cas ce qu il
faut réserver un sort particulier aux
réfugiés chrétiens de feu en vo se
souvient de la polémique sur l'accueil
des syriens notre écoute et il y en
aurait engagé je le rappelle à tous les
rêves oui je fais les immats est menacée
je préside le groupe solidarité des
chrétiens et des minorités les chrétiens
et les easy dit voilà donc évidemment
quand quelqu'un pour quelqu'un c'est la
valise ou le cercueil on lui demande pas
son certificat de baptême si j'ose dire
néanmoins néanmoins on a depuis très
longtemps depuis des siècles
tous les régimes en france et tous les
gouvernements d'ailleurs monsieur 15,9
que nous auditionnons il ya quelques
instants le rappelait sous tous les
régimes
la france a eu cette politique constante
d'accorder sa protection aux chrétiens
d'orient et les chrétiens d'orient c'est
un peu comme les abeilles vous savez en
orient dire que ce sont des indices
comment dirais-je de la démocratie en
tout cas de la tolérance est évidemment
il s'agit pas de trier et moi je les ai
vus aussi arriver les yézides y ait un
certain nombre d'autres minorités et
parce qu'un homme est un homme parce
qu'une femme est une femme
il est égal en dignité bien évidemment
deuxième partie de preuves par 3 nous
allons parler de la primaire de la
droite et du centre qui doit se dérouler
dans un an maintenant mais et helm
c'est vous le dirait un adage paul
jacques nicolas sarkozy en effet doute
de la possibilité d'ouvrir dix mille
bureaux de vote comme c'est prévu
pourtant est attesté par toutes les
parties prenantes doutent qu'ils ont été
inspirés selon son ami sénateur pierre
charon lors d'une réunion il le raconte
à quentin calmer l'ire à la réunion des
scrutins départementaux pigeot d'entre
eux ont levé le doigt en disant dix
mille bureaux de vote à raison de huit
assesseurs par bureau sa levée 80000
personnes
bon bah voilà ça nous arrange pas du
tout c'est pas du tout nicolas sarkozy
qui ne veut plus les 10000 ça a été
actée par la commission 10000 x 8 c'est
impossible à faire quand il faut que
ceux qui ont proposé ça revienne en
arrière mais certainement pas nous qui
allons faire c'est la haute autorité qui
décide on a une présidents d'autorités
on a des manques qui n'ont pas encore
tous été nommés
ça sera hôte s'est étonné mais mon petit
doigt me dit que compte tenu de la des
réflexions des secrétaires
départementaux dire que le savons tous
réunis c'était plus de 101 par
département donc là il ya pas de fionie
du pays s'imposer sans s'en fiche c'est
sûr monsieur qui vont organiser ça et
pau c'est impossible impossible sans
bureaux de vote par département c'est
impossible il faut que ceux qui l'ont
proposé par balle un peu leur salive
bonjour nana jack
non non non elle n'est pas de menace et
du tout moi je fais partie tout comme
d'ailleurs gérard larcher et et d'autres
avec nous du comité d'organisation je
peux vous assurer que nous sommes très
très attentif aux conditions et la
parcelle à écouter en tout cas au jour
d'aujourd'hui il ya une règle elle vaut
pour tout le monde pour tout le monde
évidemment simplement moi j'ai toujours
indiqué que la primaire c'est pas
tellement la règle nationale qui sera je
crois impartiale la primaire c'est tu
seras un art d'exécution et il va
falloir que les fédérations
effectivement quand on a mal dans mon
département gea peu près 120 bureaux de
vote
ça fait entre 5 600 700 personnes parce
que vous pouvez pas demander à deux
personnes uniquement de tenir un bureau
mais pas plus mal de portes et de france
au soir
si mais ça s'organise et c'est ce que je
veux dire c'est que
pour répondre à la neige plus jacques je
vois bien sûr question d'ailleurs c'est
que les règles seront des règles
parfaitement impartiale et nous les
aurons enfin en plus elles ont été
totalement ratifié par tout le monde
monsieur fillon mais oui oui
s'inquiètent les jupes plissées les
fillonnistes dont vous êtes bruno
retailleau jeudi que les règles il n'y a
pas de souci que désormais il faut que
rapidement jeu mais après les régionales
je suis désolé il ya un petit sujet
quand même avant les primaires c'est les
élections régionales mais qu'après les
régionales
le travail de chaque fédération ce sera
de dire voilà les on est capable de
tenir tant de bureaux de vote avec
tendent à ses soeurs et il faudra que il
est le plus possible de bureau doit plus
y en aura plus les gens seront incités à
se déplacer et plus la primaire aura du
poids évidemment dans cette spéciale
aura lieu il y appellera lieux et alors
je peux pas vous dire si ses 9500 10010
1500 mais elle aura lieu avec beaucoup
beaucoup de bureaux de vote ces
fondations 1500 peut-être non non je
veux dire que c'est pas une comptabilité
l'important c'est que le territoire soit
couvert et plus ils ont rien d'autant
plus dure à votants - nicolas sarkozy
c'est ça hein parce que vous tablez sur
combien de participants ou tablit ça moi
je pense je vous dire quand les français
de droite et du centre vont comprendre
que avec deux fois 2 euros ils vont
sélectionner
finalement le futur président de
république en tout cas celui qui
accédera au deuxième tour vous verrez il
y aura beaucoup beaucoup de gens je
pense qu'il y aura deux millions et demi
à 3 millions ça effet 2,9 millions d été
un gros c'est un gros score c'est un
très gros score alors la mentalité nous
on est un peu plus individualiste c'est
plus compliqué mais je pense que on
devrait atteindre 3 millions voyez alors
que s'esquisse un succès plus il y aura
de votants et - nicolas sarkozy a de
chances à ce que c'est vrai ça non sur
ses projets par personne c'est prouvé
par non parce que ceux qui la lient
cette manière de penser lui ceux qui
disent cela se disent bon il s'appuie
sur un socle le socle des militants des
adhérents du parti fin de ma famille
politique les républicains bon mais vous
et bien que si on a pour 1 million on
voit bien que c'est la loi des grands
nombres et donc ça le rallye ça
relativise tout ça alors à la ti vise
les choses pour nicolas sarkozy pour
alain juppé pour françois fillon et pour
tous les autres
donc je pense que la primaire ce sera je
pense un succès et il faut que ce soit
en même temps un succès garanti par des
règles par un nombre de bureaux de vote
qui soit incontestable et ça le sera
j'en ai aucun doute il est vrai vous
vous soutenez toujours reçu fillon
vettier fillonniste vous restez
finalistes oui oui je soutiens françois
fillon à la fois pour des raisons de qui
tiennent au coeur parce que je jeu on
s'est connu à région des pays de la
loire j'étais son vice-président et et à
la raison aussi des raisons qui tiennent
aux arguments et à son projet je pense
qu'il a à son projet que les projets
laver et déjà de l'engin qui est très
élaborée qui est assez radical parce que
je pense que le temps des demi mesures
on a vu ce que cela faisait ça fait de
se faire élire président avec justement
les mesures radicales puisque c'est un
mot qui l'emploie lui-même a d'ailleurs
pour décrire son programme la retraite à
65 ans la fin des 35 heures la fin des
prestations
enfin pas la fin des prestations
sociales je retire ce que j'ai dit avec
un discours aussi radical toujours
pareil pour reprendre le mot même
employé par monsieur fillon
on peut se raidir président ça joue ça
fait pas peur je pense que oui parce que
la peur de faire peur c'est le sang et
les larmes
souvent on dit mais attendez mais
c'était ça son propre sang les larmes si
aujourd'hui je veux dire le sang et les
larmes c'est pour le million de français
qui sont au chômage toutes catégories
confondues qui ont trouvé le chômage
depuis trois ans cela alors là on voit
bien que ils sont en train de
dégringoler et je pense que si on est
capable de porter une forme d'espérance
avec des réformes mais vous savez des
pays européens qui nous ressemblent on
fait des préformes encore plus radicale
et il s'emporte beaucoup beaucoup mieux
regardez là que votre modèle alors
modèles par mois alors moi je suis de
ceux de ceux qui considèrent que la
france elle a une histoire
elle a un avenir et elle doit réinventer
on a un modèle y compris un modèle
social faut pas le jeter aux orties
mais il faut le réinventer c'est tout
avec notre propre génie français avec
notre expérience avec ce que nous sommes
vraiment tel modèle social ces
ce que disait monsieur sarkozy si je me
souviens bien en 2007 c'est pas tout
mais il a été écouté
c'est une bonne référence 2007 il avait
été élu mais on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
plus de dépenses publiques
c'est plus d'endettement c'est plus
d'impôts c'est plus de chômage
il faut passer sur un autre modèle c'est
à dire que il faut baisser les dépenses
publiques
il faut baisser l'impôt notamment
regarder sur les entreprises
on a par rapport à l'allemagne nos
entreprises ont des semelles de plomb on
a le cou par exemple horaire est de plus
de 35 euros en france il est d'un peu
plus de 31 euros en allemagne
comment voulez vous que nous entrepris
alors qu'on a la même monnaie l'euro
comment voulez vous que nos entreprises
puissent lutter contre ça les
agriculteurs le problème agricole
français rendez vous compte qu'on a été
longtemps la deuxième puissance agricole
on est passé derrière la main derrière
la hollande la lancerons les deux tiers
du territoire sont en dessous du niveau
de la mer pourquoi pas parce que nos
agriculteurs sont pas travailleur je
peux vous assurer qu'ils font beaucoup
plus de 35 heures pas parce que nous
agriculteurs sont pas ingénieux mais
tout simplement parce qu'on a un
problème de compétitivité et si on ne le
règle pas alors oui ce sera des
lendemains qui sont sombres pour le pays
alors monsieur fillon ce programme il
expose dans un livre qui s'appelle faire
avec la fpf et une enquête est en train
de faire enquête une enquête
actuellement auprès des éditeurs
elle avait on est long du combat il l'a
vendu j'ai pour l'instant exemplaires ce
qui les habitue
voilà ce que je vais vous dire pour un
livre politique
c'est très très bien et n'a d'autre qui
font 300 exemplaires on ne donnera pas
de noms pour fâcher personne ment pas
lui l'a fait quarante mille exemplaires
quand vous expliquer ce succès libretti
direction et c'est étonnant et mamane
éditeurs qui nous a dit je viendrai pas
du tout d'abord d'abord il est passé
bien dans le livre que j'ai lu il ya
quelques semaines
le livre est bien écrit et il m'a
surpris parce que souvent on lui dit
faut absolument que tu arrives à fendre
l'armure parce que françois fillon c'est
quelqu'un qui est tout en retenue
c'est quelqu'un qui est tout en réserve
c'est quelqu'un qui se protège
énormément mais je crois que les
français un moment ou un autre ils ont
besoin
vont lui demander plus à un moment je
lui répétais vrai je lui répétais tandis
que là on on voit percer un certain
nombre de qualités humaines parfois de
faiblesse mais mais on attendait qu'elle
a aussi donné une ou deux qualités de
monsieur fillon n'ont pas s'alarmer
vivre il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous
regardent qui n'ont pas les plans sont
parlés faiblesse c'est parce que je veux
dire donc je dirais ni les qualités il
est vrai c'est un petit jeu peut alors
je vais me faire piéger
mais en tout cas j'en ai je demandé les
qualifs et services qui est le traître
est très personnel syndiqué traiterait
mais justement de ce livre est peut-être
personnellement fin mai les mairies
connu quand même pas mal l'ancien
président monsieur sarkozy en disant
écoutez moi je n'ai voulu aller plus
loin mais lui président il freinait il
freiné beaucoup
il a eu raison de faire ça parce qu'on a
un petit peu l'impression que moi je
suis pour rien sarkozy à moi dira
j'aurais bien aimé pouvoir réformer il
dit en même temps que capitaine quand
même qu'est ce qu'il dit en même temps
parce que je suis sûr vous avez vu son
livre il dit en même temps oui mais la
différence entre lui et moi c'est que
lui est élu il avait la responsabilité
suprême et moi il m'avait nommée et du
coup quand on a quand on porte sur ses
épaules une responsabilité importante
à un moment donné on ne souhaite pas que
le pays se déchirent se divise voilà non
j'étais il expliqué il aurait dû
l'expliquer alors je laisse ici quand on
le re lisez bien le passage et j'ai
trouvé justement ce passage moi aussi je
me suis quand j'ai eu livre lio la
caisse pouvait passer l'air en forme
non je trouve genre je trouve assez bien
équilibré - et ses faiblesses
parmi ces faiblesses est ce que le fait
d'avoir enduré très longtemps fait
humiliation à matignon non mais matignon
c'est un enfer sans trace je n'y ai pas
ça bâtiment matignon parce que c'est le
quotidien matignon la règle celle
interministériel matignon c'est la
machine qui fait tourner
l'administration de l'état matignon
mais mais l'elysée c'est pour ça que moi
je suis pas favorable à la suppression
du poste de premier ministre je pense
que il faut que ces preuves il faut que
présence projette loin dans l'avenir et
que par contre le premier ministre soit
les pieds dans la glaise
alors françois bayrou on l'a noté naji
propose lui un rapprochement entre votre
champion françois fillon et alain juppé
ont en les côtes
et puis vous réagissez françois fillon
est quelqu'un de d'absolument
respectable avec gd des liens amicaux
depuis longtemps mais vous voyez bien
que aujourd'hui la question est de
savoir comment s'organise
ceux qui ont cette autre vision de
l'avenir si jamais vision plus peu
viager et c'est la raison pour laquelle
lyon le faisait pas on est ce que vous
partagez cette différence près c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je souhaiterais
que françois fillon et alain juppé se
rapprochent sera que juppé on se
rapproche qu'est ce que ça veut dire à
votre avis qu'est ce qu'elle a voulu
dire par la question comment vous vous
le comprenez est-ce qu'il y en a un qui
doit se désister pour l'autre en dix ans
bah voila je me rapproche donc je me
désiste pas la solution que c'est
monsieur fillon qui le reste des
systèmes puisqu'en même temps il dit ah
ben juppé est mieux placé cicor les
sondages aujourd'hui qu'ils essaient de
mesurer pour les primaires l'avantagent
alain et le handicap de l'autre ils se
trompent tous je vous assure regardez
d'ailleurs françois hollande 18 mois
avant les primaires il était à moins de
5%
non il ya un paradoxe parce que on peut
pas dire on peut pas dire une primaire
va départager les gens et et demande aux
gens de s'effacer les uns vis-à-vis des
autres
la primaire précisément c'est un
mécanisme bayrou il fait ça pour
françois bayrou qui la dernière
l'athlète à votre derrière la tête
simplement fait présenter pour une
quatrième fois j'imagine
il refuse la primaire sur que c'est pas
le mieux placé pour donner des conseils
sur l'organisation de la primaire tandis
que 6 me seront à gagner la primaire lui
nierait pas ne se présenterait pas donc
comme nous on a l'esprit et en même
temps il a dit qu'il a envie de la
victoire de mieux pouvoir se présenter
l'adie par ailleurs qui parvint qu' il
n'était pas du tout évident qu'un juppé
a remporté la primaire je sais ça
comment gérez-vous une quatrième
candidature présidentielle de françois
bayrou
j'ai pas de jugement pour ta ces noms
vous interroger sur françois hollande
alors dans ce cas là puisque il ya
quelques jours nicolas sarkozy a dit
qu'il ne s'en préoccupait plus et que
selon lui le chef de l'état et les
socialistes d'ailleurs en général c'est
fini on écoute la seule alternative au
front national c'est nous nous
préoccuper patron françois hollande sont
finies ya plus une personne qui peut
penser une seule que c'est rattrapable
il fut un temps où santini disait qu'à
force dessus tu es dans les sondages il
avait fini par trouver du pétrole
mais lui françois hollande
il est au niveau du gaz de schiste
beaucoup plus bas alors vous aussi vous
pensez que c'est fini hollande
monsieur hollande pardon faut pas le
sous-estimer
j'ai beaucoup de critiques évidemment
vous l'avez senti d'ailleurs à faire sur
françois hollande
et j'en aurais bien d'autres que je n'ai
pas fait pour le moment mais il a une
habileté politicienne ce que je lui
reproche d'ailleurs c'est d'être moins
un chef d'état que un habile manoeuvrier
je ne sais pas s'il est finie en tout
cas je pense que c'est très mal parti
pour lui évidemment mais cette
expression gaz de schiste c'est un petit
peu bros durieux dans la com ça la
pression de la république quand même à
ce que non ils restent des références
vous avez il ya un prix de l'humour
politique
tous les ans et il a gagné non mais vous
savez que andré santini a été un de ceux
qu'il a pu paraître monsieur je vais
d'ailleurs alors dans cela le conseil
avant absolument a le plus souvent gagné
ce prêt niveau politique
donc heureusement que la politique c'est
en même temps d'humour ce serait
terrible sinon franchement ce serait
terrible quelle chance est ce que vous
attribuez à françois hollande en 2017
très peu mais je n'attribue pas une
chance qu'ils soient nuls pour les
raisons que je vous donne c'est un
habile manoeuvrier l'acte et 11 ans
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
il a réussi à éviter des écueils il a là
aucune vision malheureusement pas de
vision pas de projet ou plutôt une
réussite c'est l anti sarkozysme
même si sarkozy ça n'est pas un projet
en revanche dès lors qu'il s'agit
d'opposer les uns aux autres il faut
s'en méfier de cette conseil que je
donne à tous ceux qui voudraient la
primaire et qui se présenteront ensuite
mais on l'entend déjà évoqué ses thèmes
de campagne je me trompe peut-être vonau
retailleau qu'il avait entendu parler
vous aussi vous avez parlé du modèle
social français mais lui il veut le
défendre le sauver il est intervenu
également contre le front national
face à marine le pen peut-être
d'ailleurs que vous avez apprécié son
coup de gueule face à la présidente du
fn l'autre jour au parlement de
strasbourg
non mais c'est avec françois hollande si
vous voulez on a tout et son contraire
un jour il va vous dire on frappe à la
syrie le lendemain il va vous dire en
frappent la syrie un jour il va vous
dire on supprime les départements
l'autre jour il va vous dire on garde
les départements acceptera etc
quand on n'a pas de vision on a une
godille et ongoly en permanence donc
malheureusement dans la situation dans
laquelle le pays se trouve on aurait
besoin d'une vision et on aurait besoin
d'un président de république qui emmène
le peuple de france vers l'avenir
or on est le peuple aujourd'hui au monde
qui est sans doute le plus spécialiste
de l'historien avait eu cette très belle
phrase en disant que la france c'est un
pays qui porte le deuil de lui-même
c'est terrible c'est terrible il faut
qu'on retrouve un espoir une espérance
camus avait dit un jour aussi qu'il
fallait pas que la politique devienne
une machine à désespérer les français
bien là avec françois hollande on a une
machine à exaspérer les français donc je
crois que non et je pense qu'il n'est
pas du tout finie il faut surtout se
méfier et j'espère bien qu'en 2017 il y
aura une alternance et en tout cas avant
il ya des élections régionales il faut
impérativement que l'on puisse entamer
cette complète on en parle des
régionales merci nadège troisième partie
de preuves par 3 donc avec perrine
tarneaud et puis cette question bruno
retailleau françois hollande justement
est ce qu'il a répondu à votre
puisque vous lui écrivait que sans
évacuation des adista notre dame des
landes est bien la république montre
qu'elle est incapable de se défendre
quand un camion bruno retailleau
multiplient en quelques jours les
invectives au chef de l'état
appelé à se décider et lever toute
ambiguïté il signe ce post évoque des
habitants qui assiste impuissant à la
transformation de leur territoire en
véritable far west appuyé dans la foulée
par plusieurs interviews et des tweets
comparant notre dame des landes à damas
ou à mossoul
l'élu vendéen ajoute nous avons affaire
à des délinquants
je souhaite que la france soit la terre
de la république et d'enfoncer le clou
avec cette lettre ouverte donc adressé
directement à l'elysée sur ce territoire
perdus de la république
stop aux tergiversations françois
hollande doit recevoir une délégation
d'élus et cette phrase ce qui est en jeu
à notre dame des landes c'est la
suprématie de la loi de la république
sur la loi de la jungle
françois hollande vous a répondu non
bien sûr
bien sûr il reste dans le flou comme
comme à son habitude ce que voudrait
dire sur notre âme de landes c'est que
on pourrait être pourront peut être
contre un aéroport c'est pas le sujet
c'est la démocratie c'est le débat
normal et année encore des recours en
cour
non les recours il ya eu 154 recours qui
ont été purgées alors il y aura quelques
recours encore qu'ils ne sont pas eux
qui sont susceptibles d'appel très très
peu mais ils ne sont pas frappés si
j'ose dire des faits pour ce qui
concerne le concret mais c'était
l'évacuation à voir parce qu'il a une
absence d'autorité et de volonté de
l'état mais je tire la sonnette d'alarmé
pourquoi parce que je vois la violence
qui augmente au fil des mois il ya
quelques mois c'est le centre ville de
nantes qui est saccagée par les
analystes ensuite ce sont trois
chercheurs qui sont molestés par les
mêmes à dist il ya en moins de un ou
deux mois une voiture de gendarmerie
attaqué par des personnes cagoulées et
les brûler ce week-end un chauffeur se
perd avec son chargement son camion le
chargement il est pillée et tenir des
journalistes min
radio france bleu avec lui tout à
l'heure en audition au sénat vous l'avez
laine auditions sur les chrétiens
d'orient croiser souvent non mais ça
n'est pas bernard cazeneuve
il faut une décision de l'état et
l'édition de l'état c'est l'addition du
prison république fait l'été dernier le
premier ministre il avait dit après
justement selon le régime
oui vous l'avez dit le torse du beurre
rien ne doit stopper le 17 juillet
exactement le 17 juillet le tribunal
administratif de nantes purge les
recours des buttes tous les recours et
j'ai eu une conversation téléphonique
avec le premier ministre et me dit bien
sûr il faut évacuer
et puis non il ya quelques jours
françois hollande dit oui mais il faut
épuiser tous les recours
c'est à dire que il semblait d'irréalité
qu'intérieure aujourd'hui c'est une peur
finalement peut-être de s'aliéner
l'électorat vert peut-être
écoutez je voudrais prendre les français
à témoin est-ce que c'est supportable
que sur le territoire de la république
la loi de la république ne soit pas
appliqué ce soit la loi du plus fort la
loi de la violence ça n'est pas possible
et je constate moi en tout cas que si
l'état n'évacue pas la zad ce sera
l'état qui sera définitivement évacué de
la zad aucun républicain
personne ne peut s'en satisfaire vous
êtes vous en parler par exemple avec
jean marc ayrault
je pense que je je pense que jean-marc
un euro je vais vous dire je suis même
quasiment certain que jean marc ayrault
ne voit pas d'un bon oeil
évidemment aucun élu de la république ne
peut accepter les exactions et quand
même plus de 200 exactions rendez compte
cette violence les confrères
journalistes dans les voitures ont été
dans les pneus ont été crevés et on
n'est pas encore une fois on n'est pas
je veux dire au moyen-orient on est à
notre dame des landes comme le coeur de
la région avaient fait la raison
audacieuse non mais comparaison n'est
pas raison
je pense qu'il faut parfois des images
qui fera parce que on est devant
l'inaction de l'état et cette inaction
engendre la violence et la violence où
s'arrêtera-t-elle même si avec des
blessés graves ou pire même si c'est pas
toujours comparables vous êtes candidat
à bruno retailleau comme tête de liste
les républicains dans les
pays-de-la-loire votre ex mentor en
vendée philippe de villiers estime que
si vous êtes élu vous ne resterez pas
plus de 18 mois à la tête de la région
votre ambition vous portera plus loin et
dans sa bouche c'est pas tellement
positif alors je vous propose d'écouter
philippe de villiers puis vous réagissez
ensuite vous n'aurez qu'à y ait
quelqu'un d'ambitieux qui veut être
ministre qui sera président de la région
ciblée pour 18 mois puisqu'il est
atteint par là le cumul des mandats je
comprends pas très bien ce saute-mouton
d'ailleurs il a voulu ma place je lui ai
laissé au conseil général de la vendée
puis il est resté quelques temps comme
un météore puis maintenant il veut le
président de la région il en restait 18
mois peu après rite ministre du
numérique où tu sais pas quoi de bon
voilà et donc on est en face de lui il a
effectivement une candidate que je
connais bien qui était qui était une de
mes fidèles cécile bayle de gc qui
souverainiste et donc moi entre un
souverainiste entre une souverainiste et
un mondialiste
mon choix est fait voilà il vous est ce
que votre choix est fait entre le sénat
et la présente
voilà voilà un homme voilà un homme qui
essayait de me tuer avec une très grande
méticulosité
il n'y est pas parvenu il a l'air de
sous-entendre le contraire et qui avait
peut-être ai-je envie de le tuer en
vendée non et malheureusement
malheureusement je pense que ces propos
sont inspirés par la haine par la
rancoeur par une forme d'exécration et
je pense que la vie politique a besoin
d'autre chose a besoin d'autre chose
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai pris
pour parti de ne jamais lui répondre
jamais vous n'êtes pas dans cet état
d'esprit l'exécration papam n'est pas du
tout pas du tout pas du tout que je dis
que je pose une vraie question c'est
vrai que est ce que vous pouvez rester à
la fois sénateur président de région il
ya la limited moi je sais qu'ils sont
les seuls
est ce que vous avez observé j'étais
président du conseil général de la
vendée
j'ai renoncé ç'aurait été très facile
pour moi de le redevenir
il ne sait si je suis attaché à la
vendée eh bien j'ai renoncé pour pouvoir
me consacrer à la reconquête des pédales
wah c'est fondamental maintenant sur le
mandat je suis droit dans mes bottes
j'ai toujours considéré que le jour où
au sénat notamment mais aussi à
l'assemblée les élus n'auraient seraient
des élus hors sol qui n'aurait plus de
fonctions locales et bien je peux vous
assurer que
le sénat doublera l'assemblée il faudra
supprimer le sénat il y aura deux fois
plus d'élus puisque comme iras plus de
cumul
il faudra deux fois plus est ce que les
français veulent deux fois plus d'élus
et on aura des élus encore une fois
qu'ils sont des territorialisée la
région actuelle des pédales wah elle
souffre de pertes d' influence mais tant
que la france sera la france et qu'une
partie des décisions ça se passe à paris
bien je pense qu' il vaut mieux avoir
une influence aussi sur paris pour que
l'on puisse en bénéficier
quand vous dites non à l'ingérence des
régions pourtant on assez grande région
qui viennent de sortir de terre par la
dernière réforme du gouvernement à qui
sont donc des semaines de compétition
depuis deux mois notamment au niveau
européen alors sauf la région pays de la
loire qui effectivement ne change pas de
taille
alors regardez ça c'est aussi françois
hollande
il ya des régions qui change de taille
d'autres qui changent pas de taille
cherchez la différence la bretagne
change pas de taipei valeurs changent
pas de taille
tout simplement parce que les copains de
monsieur hollande on dit de nant faut
que la bretagne reste comme ça donc les
pays de la loire est comme sa première
incohérence deuxième à cohérence les
grandes régions pourquoi pas mais
pourquoi leur donner des compétences du
quotidien par exemple les transports
scolaires
les transports scolaires c'est des
dizaines de milliers d'enfants qu'on
ramasse tous les kilomètres chaque matin
est ce qu'une région une grande région
notamment va avoir une plus value une
valeur ajoutée dans la gestion des
transports scolaires tout ça est
ridicule dont je pense que moi les
régions doivent être en capacité
notamment sur l'emploi notamment sur
l'aménagement du territoire et de faire
des propositions
alors l'économie à l'économie mais vous
avez raison c'est râlant pour la
première fois la gauche a n'a pas
souhaité faire une loi de
décentralisation et le sénat nous avons
tenté de faire pression
on opte d'une petite expérimentation sur
pôle emploi parce que à quoi ça sert
d'avoir les leviers économiques
si on n'a pas en même temps des leviers
pour l'emploi pour faire reculer le
chômage
moi je souhaite que la région se 40 en
avant elle ce défi pour lutter contre le
chômage
est ce que vous êtes inquiet par le peu
d'appétence des français pour ces
élections régionales on annonce une
abstention à hauteur de 55% pour le
premier tour est ce que c'est justement
parce que les compétences des nouvelles
régions sont encore flous aux dires des
fraudes effet on ne vote pour les
régions que depuis peu
depuis une trentaine d'années deuxième
chose le président république a choisi
de nous faire voter le 6 décembre et le
13 décembre c'est pourquoi parce qu'il
ya là la coop 21 ans il pense que les
chefs d'état la coop 21 l'environnement
tout ça permettra de mieux réaliser la
fusion des listes ps et des listes
écolos c'est quand même incroyable
et en plus souvent c'est un vote
défouloir il ya la proportionnelle donc
les conditions sont réunies pour plier
malheureusement une abstention
maintenant faut se battre sur le terrain
faut aller expliquer aux gens que à nos
concitoyens que demain les régions vont
avoir notamment les manettes économique
l'aménagement du territoire moi je veux
pas de région de vitesse c'est important
la ruralité la fameuse france d'à côté
la france périphérique alors je vais
vous dire ce que vous avez sur le cumul
des mandats
donc vous voulez rester vous cumulards
entre guillemets même si c'est souvent
plus minable mais j'aurais vivement
est-ce que vous êtes celui qui devra
revenir donc sur le non cumul des
mandats comme nicolas sarkozy l'a
annoncé d'ailleurs absolument nous
nature cette ligne là moi je t'en es sur
son pour la libye est à venir c'est vrai
mais vous avez raison ça sera très
impopulaire en même temps en même temps
j'en ai jamais vu un de mes électeurs me
reprocher quand j'étais au sénateur
président du groupe au sénat et
président de conseil général
aujourd'hui je ne suis plus président de
conseil général et j'aspire à devenir
président du conseil régional en même
temps les français
effectivement on cette idée générale
mais en même temps ils veulent des élus
efficace et pour être efficace de temps
en temps quand il faut avoir une clé à
paris il faut que mes choix avoir un
pied auraient philippe de villiers vous
occuperez bien vos deux mangas à
j'occuperai par la blessure alors
quelques petites questions d'actualité a
beaucoup qui d'ordinaire les finances
des collectivités territoriales elle
continue à se dégrader selon le rapport
annuel de la cour des comptes publié
aujourd'hui la cour des comptes qui
préconise des économies de
fonctionnement est ce que si vous êtes
élu à la tête de la région pdl paix des
pays de la loire pardon vous serez prêt
à supprimer des effectifs bien sûr à ne
pas renouveler
il ya le statut de la fonction publique
évidemment mais à ne pas renouveler les
départs en retraite
une certaine quantité de départ en
retraite
absolument j'écoute et je les fais en
vendée c'est beaucoup plus dur parce que
les conseils généraux à l'époque
maintenant les conseils départementaux
gère le rsa gère la prestation pour les
personnes âgées
pour le handicap et donc il ya beaucoup
de par exemple de travailleurs sociaux
il ya une part de fonctionnement qui est
plus importante que pour la région
pourtant il ya un an la cour des comptes
souvenez-vous la cour des comptes avait
sorti un rapport où il épinglait
beaucoup les collectivités il y avait
trois départements qui avaient montré
qu'on arrivait qu'ils étaient parvenus à
maîtriser la masse salariale dont la
vendée je les fais pour la vendée demain
je souhaite le faire aussi pour les pays
de la loire parce que sinon parce que
sinon on a une dette qui a été multiplié
par trois en l'espace d'un peu plus de
dix ans en région pays de la loire
on a le pompon le palmarès pour
l'augmentation des impôts notamment de
la carte grise donc si on veut retrouver
des marges de manoeuvre pour investir
notamment sur l'apprentissage et sur
bien d'autres sujets il faut absolument
que le train de vie diminue oui bonjour
je sujet est ce que notre justice selon
vous est trop laxiste avec les
permissions de sortie accordé aux
prisonniers détenus bien sûr bien
évidemment vous avez sous les yeux en
quinze jours deux exemples qui sont
dramatiques
un jeune de 24 ans multirécidiviste il
avait été condamné une petite trentaine
de fois à 24 ans c'est à dire c'est
pratiquement du plein temps fiché au
radicalisme avec la notion s on le sort
de la prison et il a failli tuer je ne
sais pas où en est la vie de ce policier
mais les policiers manifestent demain
et puis récemment avec le violeur dont
vous parlez elle a été établie après sa
sortie
le violeur et puis le violeur de
l'alsace on à coup sur coup deux
exemples mais la culture de l'excusé du
laxisme c'est fini
madame taubira dès qu'elle applique des
mesures est arrivé plus peines planchers
la suppression des trente six mille
places de prison écoutez cet été elle a
même envisagé
elle a même envisagé de faire bénéficier
à ceux qui conduisent sans permis de
conduire une sorte de traitement
l'instable contravention une simple
contravention alors que vers que quand
vous êtes taubira qui responsable de
tout ça mais est-ce qu'il faut une
nouvelle ère elles avaient encore pu
lutter avec toutes les parties
la politique c'est des actes et c'est
assumer les conséquences des actes que
madame taubira prêche prône le lac 6
ça la regarde mais ça crée des
conséquences pourquoi depuis très
longtemps pourquoi les policiers demain
n'iront pas manifester pour avoir un
meilleur salaire et les iront manifester
pour faire leur métier
simplement ils iront manifester ou place
vendôme sous les fenêtres de
l'environnement quelles mesures pour
apaiser la colère de ces policiers qui
rend manifeste c'est au gouvernement
c'est au gouvernement de le dire
évidemment mais il faut rétablir les
mesures que le gouvernement a détricoté
mais il ya des effectifs aussi par
exemple aux policiers qui ont été
supprimés un sous le quinquennat sarkozy
les mesures les mesures que nous avions
notamment sur les multirécidivistes
notamment sur les peines plancher
notamment sur le programme de
construction des prisons
toutes ces mesures ont les rétablir bien
sûr il faut lire et donc le programme
des écuries qu'un finalement ça va être
un retour en arrière on n'aura pas
nécessairement pas nécessairement mais
on est pragmatique
tout ça c'est ni de droite ni de gauche
à un moment donné il faut voir la
réalité et je pense que là la vie
politique c'est accepter de regarder la
réalité en face et quand il ya un
problème de le traiter
vous soutenez les policiers qui les gens
d'organiser sur mais la rue bien sûr je
soutiens alors il ya une mise en garde
un des leurs un des leurs est en train
je lutte entre la vie et la mort
évidemment parce que un dangereux et
délinquants et et c'est loin de l'esprit
de charlie après les attentats janvier
dernier évidemment on va finir avec la
crèche de noël alors sa crèche de noël
général de vendée
vous aviez installé une crèche de noël
dans le hall du conseil général de la
vendée le tribunal administratif l'avait
interdite au nom de la laïcité et puis
la cour d'appel est revenu aujourd'hui
sur cette décision
alors est-ce que vous allez la
réinstaller non plus conseil général de
vendée mais peut-être au conseil
régional
l'avp jeannois vous êtes élu je suis sûr
qu'elle sera en tout cas pour ce concert
de la vendée et le hall du conseil
général qu'elle sera du conseil
départemental elle sera réinstallée donc
là il simplement
mais non mais j'ai toujours lui bord
pour vous est ce que c'est une défaite
pour la laïcité et non non non écouter
très très franchement il faut voir dans
la crèche et je crois que les juges ont
été en vue cette sagesse il faut voir là
dedans la crèche non plus un symbole
religieux mais le symbole de nos racines
de notre patrimoine
noël c'est la crèche je suis désolé noël
c'est en même temps des étoiles est-ce
qu'on va supprimer à l'elysée le tirage
de la galette des rois
non voilà et je veux dire qu'il nommait
pour vous la crèche un signe religieux
c'est pas le nom je pense que ça fait
partie du jeu la laïcité pour moi la
laïcité ça organise dans l'espace public
une neutralité de l'état
ça permet d'organiser la coexistence de
différentes religions
ceux qui croient au ciel ceux qui n'y
croient pas mais je suis chaud aussi une
interview style fiers de notre société
autour des tutsis oui c'est vrai sont
chers et recoins non mais je suis fier
que le tribunal que la justice
finalement et est reconnu par les eaux
alors oui on installe réunion conseil
régional
je pense que ce qui a beaucoup compté
aussi c'est que voyage avaient obtempéré
on m'avait demandé certains m'avaient
demandé de la laisser est absolument
contre les vacances mais je n'ai pas à
juger obtempéré mais je pense que
j'avais raison
il valait mieux obtenir une décision
sereine et j'en appelle à l'apaisement
sur ces questions en même temps que j'en
appelle à la fierté d'assumer nos
racines notre patrimoine c'est tout
merci bruno retailleau mères vos pères
et mères aux chaînes l'invité sera jean
luc mélenchon la semaine prochaine et
vous n'oubliez pas bien sûr ce soir sur
public sénat 22 heures on va plus loin
avec sonia mabrouk et paul bouffard
bonsoir
oui